(upbeat music)
And we're going to start this morning
as we look at basically what we do
in terms of care every single day,
which is health promotion and prevention.
Now, I have nothing to disclose
that in any way is gonna provide,
present any bias in the information.
We're gonna look at health promotion,
prevention, and screening.
The three leading causes
of preventable morbidity and mortality.
How do we counsel patients?
And how do we reinforce the necessity of patient education,
which is a lot of what we're doing today.
"What do you mean, Dr. Weismiller?
You're not gonna be doing a clinical breast exam
to screen for cancer.
And I don't need screening for cervical dysplasia.
And I don't need a bimanual exam.
Are you a doctor?"
I am. What arm do you want your flu shot in?
Okay, so there's a lot
of education going on here constantly.
Okay, so if we think about health promotion,
most of this is going to revolve
around lifestyle modification.
And we're gonna look at the three leading causes
of preventable morbidity and mortality in the US.
Because everybody's coming in thinking,
well, I need this, I need this, I need that.
But your responsibility, my responsibility,
because 60% to 70% of my week,
every single week, I'm directly seeing patients
and I'm taking the science that's available to me
and helping that patient make the best healthcare decision.
Where I feel strongly, I let the patient know that.
But my responsibility is to not make the decision,
but help them make the best decision.
Now, every individual though comes
with a complete background.
And if you think about it,
I had a patient who's in his forties.
He looked on the Nevada Vaccine Registry.
If I ever become Surgeon General,
there'll be a national registry.
No longer state registries.
But he was looking on there.
And it showed that way back in like,
I don't know, 1990, he should have had a chickenpox vaccine.
He's 40 something now.
He goes to the pharmacy.
And they gave him a chicken pox vaccine.
I'm like, you didn't need that.
Why did the pharmacist give you that?
"Well, it said I needed it."
Okay, well, that's why you need somebody working with you.
Because otherwise, you just check things off
and say, "I need this, this, this, and this."
"Well, why didn't I need it?"
Because you've been exposed.
"I've never had chickenpox."
By the age of 45, 99.9999% of people have been exposed.
That's why we don't check a titer
before we give you the SHINGRIX.
If you look at pregnant women,
women of reproductive age, "Oh, I didn't have,
I've never had chickenpox and I got exposed."
We'd always check a titer before we give VZIG
because 90% will be seropositive.
Okay, secondary prevention.
That's where we're going to find something early,
intervene, and change the outcome.
Tertiary prevention, we spend a lot of time
with in academic health centers.
You know, you got a bad disease.
We're trying to maximize function
and minimize further compromise.
And then quaternary prevention
is the newest kid on the block.
This is a set of health activities to mitigate
or avoid the consequences of unnecessary intervention.
Of course, this is what I refer to as first doing no harm.
Now, here's examples of quaternary prevention.
You know, it sounds like a UTI in that 52-year-old woman.
But I haven't done a UA or urine culture.
I just treat.
Don't routinely recommend home glucose monitoring
for patients who have type II diabetes
and they're not on insulin.
What are they doing with that?
You've seen 'em come in.
Tons of numbers.
Oh, yeah. They look all good.
Yep, good.
Avoiding unnecessary screening.
You know, screening a woman who's 80
for cervical dysplasia or, you know,
doing a stool-based study
and they just had a colonoscopy last year.
Okay, that's all unnecessary.
Avoiding admission or preoperative chest x-rays.
Both the American College of Radiology
and the American College of Surgery say
before elective surgery not involving the chest,
you should not do a preoperative chest x-ray.
It doesn't change the outcome of the procedure.
It advances further radiation,
therefore gives them something else,
and doesn't change the outcome.
Hmm.
And don't place women,
even those at high risk, on activity restriction
to prevent preterm birth.
Doesn't make any difference.
Creates more anxiety for them and they'll get a DVT.
But it doesn't change the outcome of the preterm birth.
So those are all examples of quarternary prevention.
Now, some of you are probably familiar with Choosing Wisely.
Who's heard of Choosing Wisely?
Oh, okay.
You guys need to come to Family Medicine Update.
Okay, this has probably been the biggest advance
in coronary prevention put forward in the last decade.
This is the American Board of Internal Medicine.
They're just winding this down.
And all of the Choosing Wisely statements are now moving on
to each homepage of an organization.
But this was an initiative by the ABIM
to have a national dialogue promoting conversation supported
by evidence, not duplicative,
free from harm, and truly necessary.
Choosing requires us
to have some judgment to set priorities.
Without it, everything just looks the same.
And that just becomes an emergency to do right this second.
So with Choosing Wisely, what started out
with 45 statements now has
over 700 statements of what not to do.
It started with five organizations.
Now there are 80.
Every American College of.
And there are now 30 countries
which have a Choosing Wisely campaign.
We are just 1 of 30.
And this was started just a decade ago.
It's absolutely incredible.
They're winding down and they're moving
to a new project called Building Trust.
Very important here.
I can think about in my own career,
I have dismissed three patients
or recommended the three patients I find a new doctor for.
And it was all about trust issues.
They didn't trust me.
And if they're not trusting me,
I didn't feel like I could deliver the best healthcare.
And that's what the next initiative is.
How do we participate in this?
How others are building trust.
And how do we do this
with our other healthcare professionals?
Okay, the AAFP.
They've moved their Choosing wisely to the homepage.
You can find all of their Choosing Wisely statements
on the AAFP website.
American Family Physician, the journal,
they have a Choosing Wisely segment
that they are including now in their monthly journal.
Okay, so here's what the practice recommendations are
in understanding quaternary prevention.
The Choosing Wisely initiative addresses overuse
of tests and treatments.
The goal is informed decision making.
Targeted interventions are needed though
as we help physicians make this change.
Think about this.
Every year in the US,
of all the literature that's published,
only 1% to 2% is ready for me
to use in practice and change the outcome.
Change the outcome for the patient.
Once it's ready, where it will change the outcome,
it takes us 10 years to adopt it.
10 years.
I am reminded of this every day as well
because students come in.
They talk about stuff.
And I'm like, you shouldn't even know about this.
This was changed a decade ago.
Hmm. Inertia.
Be careful because a lot of times, people think,
oh, you know, the patient's gonna be upset about this, okay?
But don't let that hesitation create an undue fear
for implementation here.
And you can find all your Choosing Wisely statements.
The biggest, one of the biggest proponents
of this discussion, besides the ABIM,
is the American College of Radiology.
It's incredible.
They're telling them what not to do.
They make money off this stuff.
AGA.
Don't do colonoscopies if they've had one
within the 10 years and there's no change.
They're telling their members don't do it.
What do I see?
I had a patient who I did a Cologuard on last year.
Went to see GI 'cause I think he's got a stricture
in the esophagus.
They quoted him an 8% false negative rate, and they said,
or they are gonna do a colonoscopy on him.
Ridiculous. He was screened.
We'll take a look at that.
Okay. Now, health promotion.
This is enabling people
to make their best decisions and to take control.
Now, the population as a whole has to be
in the center of this every single day.
We're not just focusing on an individual
because this is what happens
as we look at the determinants of health.
And wellness is not the absence of disease.
So how do we do this?
Well, we have to restratify.
What is your age?
What is your sex?
What's the family history, which is different than genetic.
You know, for example, 80% of breast cancers are sporadic.
15% to 20% are going to be familial.
Only 3% to 5% are actually genetic, okay?
Socioeconomic data.
It is a determining factor.
Lifestyle choices, environmental factors,
and then, of course, medical issues.
And then we gotta counsel
and we gotta read the patient correctly.
Are they ready to change?
This doesn't have to do just with,
are you ready to stop smoking?
Are you ready to get your blood pressure under control?
Are you ready to get your diabetes under control?
Are you ready to start some type of physical activity?
My question always is,
how many days a week do you think or say this out loud?
Yep, time to go do my exercise.
"Well, Dr. Weismiller, I never say that."
Okay, well we got a place we can start.
What would it be like to say it once a week?
Not that you have to go someplace.
It's just that it's scheduled.
Just like you got here to see me today.
But this requires motivational interviewing.
What am I going to gain from this?
And a lot of education.
A lot of education.
I mean, you think about it.
Of all the self-help measures to help with blood pressure,
cutting back on the sodium, cutting back on alcohol,
physical activity, weight loss has the greatest effect.
It will lower the blood pressure.
If you lose 10 kilos,
it will lower your blood pressure 6 to 20 points.
"I've tried everything."
How many times a week, did you say?
"Oh, I never say that."
Okay, if you're not doing any physical activity, forget it.
You can't lose weight.
Unless you're really drinking six liters
of regular coke a day.
Now, that's a different story.
You know, that's a lot of extra calories you're getting
for no benefit.
Okay, here are the steps
in administering health promotion counseling.
You gotta define the risks.
Are they ready to change?
Advocating the behavior change.
Assisting in identification of some of the target behaviors.
Reinforcing health benefits and offering resources.
Yeah, go lose 10 kilos.
I'll see you back in a year.
"Well, Dr. Weismiller,
don't you have a medication you can put me on?"
Okay, if something really worked,
wouldn't everybody be on it?
Because most people are not walking
around out there thinking,
I am at the best weight I can be at.
Similar to, we'll take a look in a moment,
if I had something that would make you quit smoking,
wouldn't everybody be on it?
Nobody's walking around out there,
thinking this is the best thing I do.
Now, the USPSTF.
Keep in mind.
We are focused on the published recommendations.
Those are the most current.
Not draft. Published.
With the Affordable Care Act,
if it's a USPSTF A or B recommendation,
your insurance has to cover it.
Now, here are the top 20 recommendations
I see show up most often on the exam.
I would definitely review those.
There are overall a hundred now.
But you need to definitely be aware of these.
So let's try this question.
The number one cause of preventable morbidity
and mortality in the United States today
is which one of the following?
Poverty, tobacco, excessive alcohol use, overweight/obesity.
Which is the number one cause
of preventable morbidity and mortality in the US?
Okay, you know what we call this?
This is a learning opportunity.
'Cause the number one cause of preventable morbidity
and mortality in the US is tobacco.
It is actually the number one cause in the entire world.
Number two, overweight/obesity.
Number three, excessive alcohol.
A study published in the Lancet
in 2022 showed that in the world,
in 2019, 40% of cancers were attributed
to one, two, or those three factors.
40%.
Which may be why by the end of this century,
the World Health Organization says heart disease
will no longer be the number one cause
of death in the world.
It will be cancer.
Okay. Now, tobacco use.
If there's ever a question
where one of the answers is stop smoking,
you don't need to read the question.
Just choose it.
(audience laughing)
Almost every known disease is made worse with tobacco.
There are very few exceptions.
And there are.
However, you'll still die
of your lung cancer or your heart disease
before you die of that other thing, which gets better.
Okay, overweight/obesity.
Dr. Vale's gonna talk completely about that.
I just wanna remind you that in adults,
it's a BMI greater than or equal to 25 for overweight,
greater than or equal to 30 for obese.
She's gonna talk completely about that.
And then excessive alcohol use.
Let's take a look at issues related to these three things.
Now, do keep in mind.
When we talk about kids who are overweight,
it's a percentile.
Overweight is greater than or equal
to the 85th percentile up to the 95th.
Obese, greater than or equal to the 95th percentile.
Now, here are some of the highest ranked services.
Big bang for the buck with low delivery rates.
And one of those is tobacco cessation counseling to adults.
I'm always amazed at the number of patients in our practice
where I look at their problem list,
and they smoke and they're overweight or obese,
and that's not even on the problem list.
What's on there is cough, acute knee pain.
And somebody put that on their wellness exam.
I mean, okay, I don't need to know that on the problem list.
Okay?
Now, tobacco use.
As we said, leading cause.
Some daily smokers appear to be smoking fewer cigarettes.
You decrease your risk of lung cancer by smoking fewer.
Heart disease only by,
decreased by smoking none.
We know that sustained,
adequately funded comprehensive state tobacco programs lead
to further reduction in smoking.
480,000 deaths per year.
Every day, about 1,600 young people
under the age of 18 try smoking.
200 of those are gonna become daily smokers.
One of five US adults continue
to use some form of tobacco product.
Look at the cost.
$300 billion each year,
including more than $225 billion in direct medical costs.
It's an enormous issue.
Here's the USPSTF in January of 2021.
Recommends the clinicians ask all adults about tobacco use.
Advise them to stop smoking
and provide behavioral interventions
and US FDA-approved pharmacotherapy.
Pregnant women, we do the same thing.
It's just we don't offer the pharmacotherapy.
We just don't have adequate data.
What about electronic nicotine delivery systems?
The data is still an I recommendation
in terms of does it help
with decreasing or stopping smoking.
We've got issues related
to effectiveness and safety, which we don't know.
So it continues to be a category I.
As we look at children and adolescents,
we wanna prevent initiation.
And therefore, we have to at least include education
and brief counseling to prevent initiation.
Very important.
School age adolescents.
B recommendation.
Cessation, it's an I recommendation
when you're looking at school age children and adolescents.
It's not that you shouldn't quit.
It's just we don't data that supports it.
It intuitively makes sense though.
Now, what's this by the numbers?
One half of people who smoke will try to quit each year.
Only 1 in 20 will have abstinence beyond six months.
About 2% to 3% who attempt to stop smoking will quit
with no pharmacological or behavioral intervention.
You gotta have this.
Now, as we look at smoking cessation and intervention.
First-line drugs if you smoke more than a half pack per day.
Less than half pack per day, is it benefit?
We don't know.
Clinical interventions.
Me talking with you for as little
as three minutes makes a difference.
And if you combine behavior
with smoking cessation pharmacotherapy,
you improve your cessation rates.
Now, there are three FDA approved medications.
There's nicotine replacement therapy.
There's bupropion.
And there's varenicline.
Psychosocial therapy,
behavioral therapy are critically important here.
Now, before you throw up your hands
and say, "Oh, they don't work,"
ask your patient when they come in and say nothing works.
Well, how'd you get started on it?
Because none of these medications will make you quit.
They're designed for people
who have quit to help them through withdrawal.
"Well, I went to my doctor,
and I said I really wanna quit smoking, but I can't.
So give me something.
And they gave me something and it didn't work."
Well, of course it's not gonna work.
I could told you that before you got started.
That's not how it's designed, okay?
They're designed for people who have quit.
Being in the hospital, I have not decided to quit.
Somebody has forced me to quit
'cause I can't smoke in the hospital.
The residents are always like beside themselves with me
'cause I'm like, if they can get up
and go outside and smoke, let 'em smoke.
I mean, I can't make 'em quit.
I can advise you should quit.
But me forcing you to stay in your bed
and not going out to smoke does not help you, okay?
Okay, here are the behavioral changes.
It's rarely gonna be a single event.
It's a gradual process.
Think about anything you've had to change.
Motivational interviewing?
Stages of change model.
The 5 As.
Ask, advise, assess, assist, arrange.
Any of them can be possible.
The one I use most often is the 5 As.
But I also do motivational interviewing.
How do I move somebody to that action stage?
Now, telephone quit-lines, they work.
It's 3:00 AM. I want to smoke.
Who do I call?
Not Ghostbusters.
I need the telephone quit-line.
It offers additional benefit when I combine it
with physician advice and pharmacotherapy.
Okay, let's try this question.
Which of the following is true regarding the use
of antidepressants for smoking cessation?
Bupropion may only be used
as monotherapy for smoking cessation.
It's unsafe to use in patients with heart disease.
The United States Public Health Service guidelines
on tobacco cessation recommend the use of SSRIs.
The guidelines on tobacco cessation recommend
against the use of all tricyclics.
Or bupropion is contraindicated
in a patient with an eating disorder.
Okay, excellent.
E is the correct answer.
Bupropion is contraindicated
in patients with an eating disorder.
Okay, so here's smoking cessation.
First line.
Nicotine replacement.
Bupropion or varenicline.
Now, in general, most third party payers have wanted you
to fail nicotine replacement and bupropion
before they'll approve varenicline.
The controllers.
Bupropion, varenicline, or a nicotine patch.
And then the relievers.
The gum, lozenge, inhaler, or nasal spray.
Now, keep in mind, a lot of people don't know
how to use the gum correctly.
It's not something you chew like Bubblicious, okay?
What you do is you chew it
until you start to get that tingling sensation
i.e. that means the nicotine is being released.
And then you park it.
You put it between your cheek and your gum
and it just sits there, okay?
And then when you get that urge again,
you pull it back out and chew a couple more times
so you start getting that tingling sensation again, okay?
So as we look at how we use controllers,
they are going to be helpful
in reducing the impulse to smoke.
Relievers work in managing those acute cravings, okay?
Now, second line agents.
These are, neither of these gonna be FDA approved.
But nortriptyline can be used.
And clonidine can be used.
If I'm concerned about any given individuals,
these are the groups.
Medical contraindications,
I'm not smoking a lot, pregnant or breastfeeding,
and adolescent smokers.
Those, we just don't have really a lot of data
on what is going to work in these individuals
and/or no studies ever gonna be done.
We don't do studies in pregnant women looking
at you take this and I won't take this
and we'll see what happens.
Now, the nicotine replacement therapy.
What you're trying to do here
is kind of stabilize the patient's nicotine dose.
And you can try to approximate
what they get in terms of cigarettes.
One cigarette contains about two milligrams of nicotine.
So you can see if they're smoking,
you know, a pack a day,
that's gonna be the equivalent
of 40 milligrams of nicotine.
And what dose is gonna maybe needed
to mitigate those symptoms?
Now, this particular class
of drugs offers you the greatest flexibility
in terms of dosage.
You can use a combination of long and short acting
because that's going to increase your risk
or your likelihood of cessation by about a quarter.
You get greater abstinence with a patch, long acting,
plus an acute form for breakthrough craving,
especially in those who are highly addicted.
Now, how do you know that?
Mrs. Jones, how long after you get up
in the morning do you have the first cigarette?
"Dr. Weismiller, I have it before I get out of bed."
Okay, that's highly addicted.
Or do you get up in the middle of the night and smoke?
Now, taking any form of nicotine replacement,
half or more likely to sustain smoking cessation
for at least six months than if you don't.
And the number you need to treat there is 17.
Now, what you would like to do, potentially,
there is some evidence now supporting starting this
before they quit.
So you want to set a quit date.
And similar to varenicline,
now with nicotine replacement,
you may do better if you start before the quit date.
I'm afraid I'm gonna get addicted to this.
Dependence is uncommon.
Now, what about cardiovascular disease here?
All the nicotine replacements are associated
with an increase in chest pain.
You do not see though an increase
in major cardiovascular events.
However, you don't want to use these
if somebody's had an acute MI within the past two weeks.
That is not going to be suitable.
Or, you know, they've had some kind
of life-threatening arrhythmia.
You do not want to be using these.
Now, what about the antidepressants in smoking cessation?
Bupropion and nortriptyline are effective.
The other TCAs, the anxiolytics,
the SSRIs, they are ineffective, okay?
So we really don't have a class effect here.
Now, bupropion, what we're looking at
is the sustained release formulations.
Here, we're 64% more likely to quit at one year.
Bupropion and nicotine together,
there's really no significant improvement in cessation,
except if I'm going to use it as a craving reliever.
There, I might get benefit.
This can also be particularly helpful in patients with COPD.
That's what the epidemiologic data shows.
And it's safe to use if you have coronary artery disease,
even in hospital settings.
If you have unstable angina
or it's an acute coronary syndrome,
this is the least of your problems.
We wanna deal with that first.
We're not gonna be dealing with putting them on bupropion.
Contraindicated.
Seizure disorder,
medications that lower that disorder, seizures,
a significant head injury,
or if we've got anorexia, or nervosa, or bulimia.
In terms of the long acting.
Now, varenicline or Chantix.
This is the most effective.
This is a partial alpha-4 beta-2 nicotine
and acetylcholine receptor agonist.
And it also blocks nicotine receptors.
So you get this small amount of dopamine,
which is going to be released.
This is what is similar to the release by nicotine.
So it relieves the cravings.
In addition, you relieve the withdrawal symptoms
because you're directly blocking the receptor.
You're 2.2 times more likely to have cessation
at four weeks in a year compared with placebo or bupropion.
Here, the number needed to treat is only seven.
So it is the most effective,
particularly at that six month mark.
Now, if we think about medications,
here is where the scenario is changing just a bit.
There is evidence now that varenicline
is actually helpful in making you quit.
Making you quit.
Now, the side effects.
Nausea is gonna be the biggest one.
FDA alerts here.
Black box warning was removed way back
in 2016 related to psychiatric events.
There's a possible increased risk
of adverse cardiovascular events
if you have cardiovascular disease.
And it may change the way people react to alcohol.
So be careful there.
Here's the summary then.
7, 14, 17.
Look at nortriptyline though.
If they can tolerate it.
11 is the number needed to treat.
Length of treatment.
This is the issue related to varenicline.
And perhaps it is helpful as a controller therapy
and lowering relapse rates.
The number needed to treat here is 19.
But the American Thoracic Society
said you're probably gonna need to be on it up to a year.
Getting that paid for can be problematic.
There was a randomized controlled trial in 2021.
They did not find the improved abstinence
that the American Thoracic Society has seen.
So it's going to be interesting to see
how this all comes out in the wash.
How do you optimize success?
Timely follow up.
Within a week of the quit date.
Why is that?
In the first few days of abstinence,
that's when you're gonna have the highest risk of relapse.
And they're gonna need additional follow up
in terms of office visits or some kind of printed material
or some type of electronic material sent out to them.
Now, we define relapse.
Smoking on second consecutive days
or smoking once each week over two consecutive weeks.
It's very common.
Most people will try to quit anywhere
from four to five times
before they have finally quit, quit.
Strategies. How do we help prevent this?
What are the cues?
What are the behaviors?
What are the benefits?
Celebrating?
How long have you had or been abstinent before?
"Oh, I was absent him for three years."
We know you can do this.
Okay, obesity.
I just wanna remind you here.
The USPSTF 2018 recommends
that clinicians offer or refer adults
with a BMI 30 or higher
to intensive multi-component behavioral interventions.
That's a B recommendation.
For children and adolescents, 2017, refer them
to comprehensive intensive behavioral interventions
to promote improvements in weight status.
Dr. Vale is going to completely cover this in its entirety.
One other recommendation from the USPSTF
in 2020 recommends offering referring adults
with cardiovascular disease risk factors
to behavioral counseling interventions
because we wanna get them
to a healthy diet and physical activity
where you've got weight excess and cardiovascular disease.
Now, here is the recommended activity levels
for individuals.
It's 150 minutes per week for weight maintenance.
It's double that if you're trying to lose weight.
Important.
You also need to combine the aerobic activity
with weightlifting.
And the recommendation is at least two times a week,
you work all the major muscle groups.
That's why every place you go now,
in terms of a gym, they all have a weightlifting class.
High repetition, low weight, okay?
Because working every major muscle group
is really important.
Alcohol, our third leading cause
of preventable disease and death.
Let's take a look at this particular question.
Which following statements
is true regarding alcohol abuse counseling?
The CAGE, but not the AUDIT tool,
has been validated as a screening instrument
for adult for alcohol abuse.
The USPSTF recommends screening
and counseling adolescents on the risks of alcohol misuse.
A woman consuming more than one drink per day
on average is considered to be a heavy drinker.
When considering a standard drink,
a regular beer is considered to be 16 ounces.
Okay, let's see what we got here.
Okay.
Well, we have a learning opportunity.
More than one drink per day
on average is considered to heavy.
Okay, so let's take a look at this.
Again, high rank.
Big bang for the buck.
We don't do a good job screening adults
for problem drinking.
Okay, so here's the definitions of drinking.
Here's how I ask questions about,
how I ask patients about this.
So, you know, you're coming in for a wellness exam,
which means, really, we're gonna talk for 90% of the time.
And interestingly enough,
if you want to really get riled up,
go to the recent Society of General Internal Medicine
Choosing Wisely.
These are the internists.
You know them.
They no longer recommend an annual visit.
The data does not support it.
That it should be focused.
And doing annual blood work?
Not recommended.
The data doesn't support it.
That's the internists.
They have, you know, fallen on their sword on this.
And no extensive physical exam, which is what I do.
You know, any acute issues? Nope.
Okay, well let's start with the three leading causes
of preventable disease and death.
And then we're gonna go through primary,
secondary, tertiary, and quaternary prevention.
But when I get to the third one,
which is alcohol, here's the question.
Do you drink daily, weekly, or monthly?
"Dr. Weismiller, I don't drink at all."
What's the follow up question?
Why not?
(audience laughing)
Okay, you're laughing.
But why not is very important.
'Cause 50% of the time, it's because they're in recovery
or there's a family member with an alcohol use disorder.
So you have to ask that question, okay?
Most people will have something.
It's fine not to drink.
That's not the question here.
I don't wanna miss something.
And you will miss them, okay?
Now, for men, two or less, or women, one or less,
because women make less alcohol dehydrogenase.
Heavy drinking.
More than one per day for women.
More than two per day for men.
After I say, okay, do you drink daily, weekly, or monthly?
"I have two drinks per week."
Then I ask about binge.
How many times? How often?
How often, excuse me, do you have,
for men, five or more drinks over a two hour period?
"Dr. Weismiller, I never do that.
I'd be on the floor."
Or, you know, "Maybe once a month."
Okay, so binge is not uncommon.
More people will binge drink.
But they're not alcoholics.
The other thing is, what's a standard drink?
"Okay, I have two drinks per day."
Do you get those at a bar or do you make 'em at home?
"Oh, I make 'em at home."
Okay, so most people are not getting something out
to measure when they make it at home.
So I have one patient right now
who thought he was having two drinks a day.
He is actually having six drinks per day.
Okay?
So unless you ask,
because remember, there are no poor historians,
just poor history takers.
Poor history takers.
Okay, here is the CAGE and the AUDIT.
They are two validated instruments.
You all know about the CAGE.
The AUDIT is actually better.
It was developed by the World Health Organization.
What it's trying to do is determine
if the alcohol consumption is harmful.
It has been internationally validated.
Three questions deal with consumption.
Four to six relate to dependence.
Seven to ten, alcohol related problems.
If you add up a score of 20 or more,
that's suggestive of alcohol use disorder,
alcohol dependence.
Okay, so we've discussed quaternary prevention.
So we're gonna now discuss primary, secondary,
and tertiary prevention.
Primary prevention
is where we avoid the development of a disease.
This is where most of our population health is focused.
And, of course, the best example,
despite the fact that many believe
that COVID is a conspiracy,
just so you know, it is,
and we are going to next solve world peace together.
Immunizations were one
of the greatest advances of the last decade,
or, excuse me, the last century
in terms of illness prevention.
I mean, you think about it.
At the turn of the last century, 1900,
the average age of death was 48.
And a lot of that is skewed
because if you go back and read about anybody,
1910s, 1920s, 1930s,
I'm watching a series right now on the Roosevelts.
They all had a child die.
You know, people died in their forties and fifties
from, you know, renal disease and things
because we didn't have treatment for it, okay?
So it's been the greatest advance.
I was very curious as a marker
to help people understand risk.
Now, how many of you leave the house
in the morning thinking about I could die
in a car accident today?
Yeah, okay. One of you.
I have a couch outside.
You can lay down on that and we'll do therapy.
No, I'm just kidding.
No, but, and yeah.
As you see, most of us now see it.
You're two and a half times more likely
to die any given day from a car accident
than you are from getting an immunization.
Now you think, well, two and a half times.
That's not much.
But nobody in here except
for our one colleague there is thinking about,
I'm gonna die in a car accident today.
So they're driving to get their COVID vaccine
and they're likely to be dying from that,
i.e. in a car accident,
not from getting the vaccine itself.
And any long-term problem that was ever identified
with a vaccine has been known
within eight weeks of it being administered.
We've never been eight years trying to figure out,
oh, my gosh, we didn't think about that.
Eight weeks.
And I've decided that when I finally go
to my last resting place,
I think the last words from my mouth will be,
"You cannot get the flu from a flu vaccine."
(audience laughing)
I'm convinced that those are gonna be my dying words.
Okay, here are the general principles.
Serious side effects are exceedingly rare.
Every visit's an opportunity for primary prevention.
If you come to see me in the office,
you're gonna get a shot.
I don't care why you're there.
You're gonna get one 'cause you need one.
And I have learned,
because my philosophical approach is when,
as primary care physicians, if we're out of vaccines,
that's like me going to McDonald's and we're out of fries.
You know, I mean, who wants to go there and be out of fries?
Okay.
So I've learned now.
One of my full days of clinic every week is all day Monday.
And I've learned now that if they're running low
on vaccines on Friday,
they start telling people there are no more
'cause they don't want me coming in on Monday morning
and asking for a vaccine and then not be available.
'Cause I tend to not be in the best mood then, you know.
Okay, a 25 millimeter needle
should be used instead of a 16 millimeter.
It reduces the risk of adverse reactions to the vaccine
because you embed it deeper.
You never restart an immunization series.
And I remind this to patients
whenever they tell me, "Oh, yeah.
I got my first SHINGRIX, but I didn't go back."
I don't care if it was 20 years.
You go back.
You get your second then you're done.
If you get your first Gardasil when you're 12
and you don't come back until you're 22,
you get a second one and you are done.
We never restart it.
Now if you have no idea what the immunization schedules are,
you have to pull them up.
We're not gonna go through every immunization.
We used to do that.
And it was just a litany of problems.
And people are like, this is boring.
And it is.
'Cause you just gotta go to the schedules and look at 'em.
They were published on February 1st, okay?
Key points to the 2022 schedule.
I just wanna remind you.
'Cause these will come up.
Vaxelis contains DTaP,
inactivated polio, Haemophilus, and hep.
You can figure out.
There's a lot of information now
on how you can include that in any schedule.
In addition, although MMR
and Hepatitis A are both recommended at 12 months,
infants aged 6 to 11 months
who are undergoing international travel should get one.
So they would then receive a two dose series.
Only one Haemophilus influenzae b after 15 months
and none are done after 60 months.
Total number of doses of any vaccine.
Pneumococcus, polio.
Vary depending on how old the child is, okay?
If they're not already fully vaccinated.
Now, vaccine refusal.
AAFP, they say we don't really support this.
But they do recommend signing a vaccine refusal form.
If you're looking for one, you can go to the AAP.
They have one.
And they accept the practice
of dismissing an individual from your practice
if it's done in a conscientious way.
Those are the pediatricians.
They say, "You're outta here."
The CDC does not recommend that, okay?
I have modified that AAP pediatric form
for my practice for an adult form
because that's how important this is to me.
And recently, I had a family member
who was asking about on social media,
which I try to avoid, about a flu vaccine.
I'm like, one, you should have got it way back in October.
And then everybody weighing in.
And here's what I learned in seeing everybody weigh in.
One, you know, don't tell me,
"Oh, I gotta do my research."
Okay, that means you're reading something
because you agree with this particular perspective.
That is not research.
Two, there was not one comment
about the public health aspects of this.
It was all about me, me, me, me, me.
You know, and everybody says,
"Don't tell me I have to get a vaccine.
Why should the government tell me that?"
Well, here's my example.
I want to go into Walmart naked smoking a cigarette.
But they won't let me do that.
The government says I cannot do that.
I'll be arrested.
Why can't I? It makes me feel good.
Okay, which immunization would be considered safe
to administer during pregnancy?
MMR, HPV, Tdap, or varicella.
Which one are we gonna give?
Safe.
Okay, so Tdap.
Now, you think about this.
A decade ago, a Tdap was contraindicated in pregnancy.
Now, people get confused.
We are giving mom a Tdap now in every pregnancy
to use her for yet one more facet of life,
which is to immunize passively the infant.
Now, don't get confused here.
Dad does not need a Tdap in every pregnancy,
nor do to grandparents.
They just need one boost at some time, okay?
Because remember, prior to about 2010,
we didn't boost any adult with Tdap.
They got TD.
But with the resurgence of pertussis,
because kids weren't getting immunized,
we were like, we better start immunizing everybody again
to boost everybody's immunity
from the public health standpoint, okay?
So now, at the decennial, if you've had a Tdap,
you just need a TD or Tdap.
Either one can be used, okay?
Keep in mind though,
Medicare does not pay for a Tdap or TD
unless you've stepped on a rusty nail.
Part D will.
But Medicare in office will not pay for that.
So I'm always running around, you know,
I hear, "Oh, I need a Tdap in there."
I'm like, is that patient over 65
'cause they're gonna get a bill for that, okay?
Part D will pay for it.
But the in-office does not pay for it
unless they've stepped on a rusty nail or the equivalent.
I'm always amazed.
"Oh, yeah. I need my tetanus shot.
Oh, I don't want a flu shot.
Don't want COVID."
I'm like, okay, we've had one case.
Maybe one case of tetanus a year in this country.
Okay, so those are the vaccines in pregnancy.
Tdap, every single pregnancy.
We wanna do it between 27 and 36 weeks.
As early as possible because we want all
of that rich IgG to go over to the baby.
Okay, now, here is the adult vaccine schedule 2022.
Just a couple reminders for Hepatitis B.
Two dose series at least four weeks apart.
You cannot use this during the pregnancy though, okay?
The two or three dose series can be used,
but not during pregnancy.
You need two shingles vaccines.
Even if you had the old Zostavax,
you should still get this.
It's 90% effective.
The old Zostavax at 10 years was only
about 20% effective, okay?
It was only 50% to start at the beginning.
And then Dr. Connor's gonna go over this all again.
But remember, we have now moved to PCV20.
Now you think, well, why did they need an app
if PCV20 is so simple.
Because we're in a period of complex people
because they've had some and not the others.
But eventually, everybody's just gonna get one PCV20
in their life.
Either at 65 or if you need it earlier than that,
you just get the one.
That's all you need to remember.
If they're naive, they get one PCV20.
It's given at 65.
Or if they have a high risk condition,
then they get it early.
Now, what about the Monkeypox vaccine?
ACIP recommends vaccination with two dose vaccine series
if you're 18 or older 28 days apart.
Who's at risk?
Gay, bisexual, other men who have sex with men,
transgender or non-binary people
in the past six months who had one of the following.
Sexual partners of persons with the risks above.
Persons who anticipate experiencing any of the risks above.
2024 immunization schedules.
You're going to, they've been linked there.
You can find those on your own.
Secondary prevention.
I'm gonna get to something early and make a difference.
We're gonna use as an example breast cancer.
Now, there are not two words
in the English language that evoke more fear.
I understand that.
However, we're gonna take a look at the current data.
It is the most common cause,
with the exception of skin cancer,
of cancer in women.
It's the second leading cause of death.
Lung cancer is more common in terms of death.
Some women will have an inherited cancer
susceptibility gene called the BRCA mutation.
Here's how you screen for that.
I'm seeing a patient.
Mrs. Smith, has anyone
in the family had breast, ovarian,
tubal, or peritoneal cancer?
"Dr. Weismiller, nobody's had breast, ovarian cancer.
I don't know what tubal or peritoneal cancer is,
so I don't think they've had that either."
Okay, their risk of BRCA is zero.
If they answer yes to that one question,
then you go on to use one of these tools,
which has been put forward
by the USPSTF on their website.
I use either this referral screening tool or the FHS 7.
If they answer, if they screen positive
on one of these tools because they answered yes
to that one question,
then they are offered genetic counseling.
And a genetic counselor
will do a two generation pedigree analysis.
If they turn out to be BRCA positive,
you can consider prophylactic oophorectomy and mastectomy.
Keeping in mind though
that we now understand that ovarian cancer
does not arise from the ovary.
It arises from the tube.
That's why you will see more
and more women having a tubal removal
as opposed to a tubal ligation
if they have completed childbearing
and are going for sterilization.
Cancer Genetic Studies Consortium.
If you're not gonna do this,
you can see there the screening is pretty intense
in terms of increased risk.
Now, here's the current published guideline.
I checked last night.
The new draft has not yet been published.
50 to 74, it's a B recommendation.
40 to 49, a C recommendation.
In the 50 to 74, it should be done every other year.
Here's the draft statement,
which is awaiting publication.
It's dropped to 40 every other year.
There is no new data, empiric data.
What there is
is they did six different modeling techniques.
Looking at this group of 40 to 49.
It's a different disease than people
who develop over the age of 50.
And still with the modeling,
for every thousand women you screen,
you only save one life
between the ages of 40 and 49.
But if 40 to 49,
every other year is what's gonna be recommended.
That's optimal.
Biennial schedule preserves most of the benefits.
Now, what are the recommendations of others?
American Cancer Society,
no clinical breast exam at any age
for screening for breast cancer.
So we don't do a breast self exam.
That doesn't screen for breast cancer.
No clinical breast exam unless there's symptoms.
Now all of you're thinking, but I found.
Of course you did.
But when we look at large studies
and how do we spend our time with patients,
the clinical breast exam has not been shown to save lives.
What we do need to practice though is breast self-awareness.
Okay.
You know, I had a patient.
I don't think I put,
I know I didn't put this picture in there.
But, you know, she came in.
She said, "I had 10 days of this,
of a lump that came up."
Do an exam. Open up her gown.
I'm like, okay, 10 days, I'm thinking.
Okay, lump.
Big retraction of the breast.
Nipple retracted.
Okay, that's breast self-awareness, you know.
Or I had another patient who came in
and said, "My boyfriend says one
of my breasts is larger than the other."
You know, I do an exam.
Your boyfriend?
She had an inflammatory breast cancer,
had all the orange,
changes in the skin.
I'm like, I'm thinking in my mind.
You didn't recognize that?
Okay.
Screening MRI.
Impact of breast cancer is uncertain.
Almost impossible to get paid for
unless you're the surgeon or oncologist.
Keep in mind the decrease
in the mortality rate of breast cancer.
Earlier detection and better follow up.
But here's where a big fiasco is right now.
We are getting into this point where we're over-screening.
And there are particularly maturing women
who are being found to have incidental findings,
essentially, which will never predict anything
for them that are undergoing treatment.
It's kinda like the story of prostate cancer,
which is, you know, everybody gets it.
It's just we cannot identify through any kind of test
who's gonna die from it as opposed to with it.
'Cause almost all men who reach the age
of eighties to nineties will have prostate cancer,
which reminds me, there are three factors
that get you to the age of 90.
He's Dr... (chuckles)
Here are the three.
Dr. Blackwell is back there thinking,
now, what is he gonna say?
Here are the three I've decided to get you to 90.
Your ability to move.
So mobility, balance, and strength.
If you're missing those three,
despite how good your health is,
oh, there he tells me.
You have, despite how good your health is,
you're not gonna get to 90.
You gotta have those three, okay?
I'm becoming a geriatrician.
Oh gosh.
Breast cancer.
Medications to reduce the risk.
Who benefits?
We apply the National Cancer Institute
breast cancer risk assessment tool.
But if they tell you
on the exam the patient has at least a 3%
or greater risk for breast cancer in the next five years,
they've risk stratified to benefiting from medication.
They're not gonna make you use the tool on the exam.
But here is the important thing.
Premenopausally, they can go on Tamoxifen.
Postmenopausally, go on Raloxifene.
Letrozole, that is not approved
for chemo prevention of breast cancer.
And postmenopausal, but in postmenopausal,
but it's not approved for premenopausal.
Combined OCPs, remember,
they decrease the risk of ovarian and endometrial cancer.
They do not prevent breast cancer.
Progesterone does not reduce the risk of breast cancer.
Keep in mind that within the women's health initiative,
remember, you were in treatment arm versus placebo.
The treatment arm had two arms.
Estrogen plus progesterone if you had a uterus.
Estrogen alone if you had no uterus.
It is the women in the estrogen plus the progesterone arm
who had the increased risk of breast cancer,
not breast cancer death.
For 10,000 patient years,
there were nine additional cases of breast cancer
in the women who were on both estrogen and progesterone.
Women only on estrogen actually had a decrease risk
of breast cancer.
And it was the increased incidence of breast cancer,
not breast cancer death.
18 years later, we now know that
that increased risk started
at about five to seven years.
Okay, tertiary prevention.
Dr. Fern Harbor's gonna talk all about heart failure.
I just wanna use that as an example.
Here's our question.
74-year-old female New York Heart Association
class II heart failure.
LV ejection fraction of 34%.
Optimal dosages of an ACE, beta blocker, Crestor.
Past medical history notable only
for a long history of hypertension.
She's a non-smoker.
Reports she has a small glass
of blush wine with dinner each evening.
Just a small one.
On examination, she has a blood pressure of 126/72.
BMI of 28.
Her chest is clear and her cardiac exam
is notable only for an S4.
Self-help measures recommended for patients
such as this include which one of the following?
A sodium intake less than 4,000 milligrams per day,
strict avoidance of alcohol,
avoiding NSAIDs,
or a weight loss program with a goal BMI of 25 or less.
Okay, so we have a learning opportunity.
It is avoiding the NSAID use.
So if you've got heart failure, no NSAIDs.
Even a dose.
Now, here are the self-help measures typically.
Although if you go to the heart failure guidelines,
and in particular if you talk to the chair of the committee
who is the lead author on those guidelines,
he would have my neck
for even having anything up there about sodium.
He doesn't even talk about it.
Unless you're a sodium sensitive,
it doesn't make any difference.
Now, I will tell you though,
a low sodium diet, less than 2,400 milligrams per day.
Here's how I tell the patient they can get
to that if they want to.
You will throw away your can opener.
And you will only use the microwave for defrosting.
That's it, okay?
'Cause anything else is gonna be high in sodium.
That is a cardboard diet.
And I will tell you.
When patient's in the hospital,
I have them on a less than 4,000 milligram diet
because I think that more likely represents
what they may be able to do at home.
Medications, echo.
We only do an echo if there's a change.
American College of Cardiology,
and they're choosing wisely,
last year said, "Do not be repeating echoes
unless there's a change."
And then a daily weight.
Self-help and chronic disease increases levels
of functioning, reduces pain,
and decreases healthcare costs.
Know those three things.
We advocate a lower sodium diet only
in those who are sodium sensitive.
Fluid restriction.
Again, only if you're fluid sensitive.
Avoiding NSAID use.
It's shown to increase the risk
for renal insufficiency and hospitalization if you don't.
And look at this.
The one place.
Actually, you do better
if your BMI is 30 to 32 with heart failure.
Now, if it's 28, do you do better if you get the 30 to 32?
We don't know that.
But in terms of reduction,
we only need to get you to a BMI of 30 to 32.
It's only encouraged in terms of weight loss
where that BMI is over 40.
If alcohol led to your heart failure, stop.
But otherwise, routine consumption is fine.
Physical activity.
Very important here.
Exercise training three to five days a week
should be considered in all stable patients
with chronic heart failure.
Lots of therapy. Lots of devices.
Dr. Fern Huber's gonna go through all of this
as we look at the goals of treatment.
So in summary, practice recommendations for you.
Lifestyle modification, counseling education,
and then looking at primary, secondary, tertiary,
and quaternary prevention with each of your patients.
And with that, I'm gonna say thank you very much.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)